The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
HONG LIU: OK let's start.
So let me just
mention brief-- first
let me just mention briefly,
this story regarding
the D-brane and the
Higgs mechanism,
which we discussed at
the end of last lecture.
So there was a P-set problem
which was related to this.
Yes, I expected maybe the
P-set problem was a little bit
tough because we did
not go to many details.
We did not go to many details.
Yeah, so in grading we will
be very flexible because we--
So let me just say a few
more things about that,
just to make sure--
So here is the action.
If you have n-- say
if you supposedly
have N D-branes together--
and then in such case--
so this is a low
energy defractive
action for the massless
degree of freedom
on the D-brane for which you
have a gauge field, which
is a matrix, and then
you also have a scalar
field, a number
of scalar fields,
which are also n-by-n matrices.
And the number of
scalar fields is
the same as the number
of transverse dimensions.
And then we also discussed
that the scalar fields
can be considered as describing
the transverse dynamics
of the brain.
Say, let's consider
you have-- let's
consider you have a single
brane and there's only
one transverse direction.
Say let's call it
the phi direction.
There's only one direction,
say phi 1 direction.
Then essentially the location
of the brane then essentially
the expectation
value of phi 1 can
be considered-- say suppose
this is the direction of x1,
and the corresponding
scalar field is phi 1.
And then the expectation
value of phi 1
can be considered
as the location
of the brane and this
phi is the string which
ending on this brain
and come back to itself.
So now let's consider if you
have two branes-- now consider
you have n-branes-- again, b is
only one transverse direction.
I now have n-branes with
one transverse direction,
which again is x1.
And now you can
just separate them.
So now let's consider the
process which you separate
these n-branes into-- say
completely separate them
in different locations.
So this is x1, x2, to xn.
So this situation can be
considered as a situation.
So in this case,
the phi is the-- phi
is the m-by-n matrices.
And then this can be considered
as phi having an expectation
value which is only
in the diagonal entry,
and each that diagonal
entry describes
the location of each D-brane.
And it's natural
to think that why
this is the diagonal entry
because the diagonal entry
describes the string, which
ending on the brane itself.
So this is a one-one
string, and this is
a two-two string, and n-string.
And so the diagonal
string is the excitation
on the brane itself.
And the off-diagonal
degree of freedom
corresponding to, essentially
corresponding to the excitation
between the string
between the branes.
And so it's natural
that the location
of the branes, and
then just corresponding
to the diagonal entries.
And so now we can generalize
to the general dimensions.
Now suppose there are two
transverse dimensions--
let me call them x1
and x2-- and then
now you have two scalar fields.
So now the story is a
little bit more complicated
because when you have two
transverse directions,
say if you have more than
two transverse directions,
now you have nontrivial
potential term.
And under the law of
the configuration,
say suppose it's five, have
low space time-dependent
on the law of configuration, say
the minimum with the potential,
the mass was corresponding
to the configuration,
which the commutative phi
a and phi b to be zero.
Right now, say we have
two transverse directions,
so we only have two, but you
can generalize to any number
of transverse directions.
So that means that
the phi, or the phi
equals 1, or the
scalar field, they
have to converge
with each other.
That means they can be
simultaneously diagonalized.
That means they
That means we can choose
a basis, say if I write
the phi, the collection
of all the D-branes,
then I can simultaneously
diagonalize them, and then
have the following form.
So each x1 goes one into--
so each vector goes one
into-- for example
here, is x1-- I should
use a different notation, so let
me call the spacetime y1, y2--
and say this is x2, et cetera.
So this defines
the configuration,
which you have one D-brane
here and one D-brane
at this point, and
at x3, and et cetera.
And again, it's only
the diagonal entry
that describes the
location of the D-branes.
The diagonal entry describe
the location of the D-branes.
And these, because they are
all diagonal and the commutator
is zero, and these are the
law of the configurations.
So this is a very
important lesson.
It tells you that even you have
a potential, still the D-brane,
you can put it
anywhere you want.
And you have the freedom
to put the D-brane-- you
don't break translations image.
Any questions on this?
Of course when you say, when
the scalar field develops
expectation value and then your
original un gauge symmetry's
broken, and then
broken into the just
in the standard
story to whatever
[INAUDIBLE] group
allowed by this--
so if all the x1-- if all
of them are different,
then the remaining just
be 1 to the power n.
Because now you just have
each brane separated,
then you just have
1 to the power n.
Good?
So not let's move to new stuff.
So now let's say I little
bit about the D-branes
in super string theory.
So what we said so
far actually applies
to D-branes in bosonic
string and in superstring.
Now let's say a little bit
more above the D-branes.
So as we discussed before, when
we quantized the open string,
the D-branes in
bosonic string always
have a tachyon-- always
have open string tachyon,
no matter what D-brane you have
because as we discussed before,
the quantization, the
zero-point energy on the string
is the same no matter which
dimension of the brane
is et cetera.
And so you always have
open string tachyon.
So that means, as we
said before, tachyon
means that you are seeking-- if
you have a scalar field which
have a negative mass squared,
that means you're essentially
sitting at the top of the
potential-- in the top
of some potential.
And so that's why you get
the negative mass squared.
And so that means
you have-- this
is an unstable configuration.
Because if you, say, give the
tachyon a little bit back,
then the tachyon
want to roll down,
and then you move away
from this configuration.
You move away from
this configuration.
So when you go to superstring--
so we also discussed before,
for the bosonic string, the
close string factor also
has a tachyon, and then you
can get rid of those tachyons
by going to the superstring.
So similarly, going into the
superstring, the D-branes
of certain dimensions--
not for all dimensions,
but only for some dimensions--
do not have tachyons.
So they are stable.
So their lowest modes
are just massless modes.
They don't have negative
mass square modes.
In particular-- so this I
will-- this is a long story.
This is a somewhat long story
which I will not explain here,
but I will just
make the statement.
In particular you can show
that for those stable D-branes
in superstring, they always
carry a conserved charge.
So I will explain where does
this conserved charge come
from, and they always carry
some conserved charged.
And which is also a reason
why they are stable.
And the second feature is
that the worldvolume theory
is supersymmetric.
So in addition to this
phi-- so in addition to this
say A alpha phi we are looking
at here, A alpha and phi a,
which we already see
in the bosonic string,
they are also massless fermions.
So the open string excitations
also include massless fermions.
They also include
massless fermions.
And in particular, the
low energy theories,
all of them together, is the
supersymmetric version of this.
It's a super-Yang-Mills theory,
And it's some kind of
super-Yang-Mills theory.
So now let me elaborate a
little bit on the first point.
They carry a conserved charged.
Let me elaborate a little
bit on the first point.
So maybe go to the one,
elaborate more on one.
So let me just remind you
again, the bosonic part of the
of massless closed
superstring spectrum,
which we briefly
mentioned before--
so this is so-called type
II string, so-called type II
string.
When I say the superstring I
always mean type II string.
So if you quantize
the superstring,
then you find that they are
again, you find the metric,
you find the graviton,
then you find
that there are
this metric tensor,
and you find that there
are scalar fields just
as what we did in
the bosonic string.
But they have some
additional massless modes.
Depending on your
quantization or how
you treat the fermions in the
superstring, then there can be,
say IIA or IIB, there are
two types of superstring.
And for IIA you have one
additional 1-form field
and additional 3-form field.
And for IIB, you have
additional scalar fields,
and additional 2-form fields,
and additional 4-form fields.
In particular, this is
so-called self-dual.
I will explain that
in a little bit.
In the IIB, contain
a self-dual 4-form.
And this additional field are
called the Ramond-Ramond field,
typically.
Just a name, it's called
the Ramond-Ramond fields.
And so this called the
Ramond-Ramond fields.
AUDIENCE: C1 and C3?
HONG LIU: C1 and
C3, that's right.
They're all called
Ramond-Ramond fields.
Yeah.
So the story is
essentially the same,
very similar as to what we
did for the bosonic string.
For the bosonic string you
only have x on one sheet,
when you quantize x then
you find the graviton,
you find those B, you find the
phi, and in the superstring
you pull some additional
fermions on the world-sheets,
and those fermions give
you additional modes,
and then you will have those
additional-- they will also
give rise to additional
massless modes in the spacetime,
and those are this
Ramond-Ramond fields.
They are also massless fermions,
which I will not write here.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So why is it that type
IIA and type IIB string theory,
they appear to be very, very
different, which seems bad.
It just seems like there's
this arbitrary choice about how
you go about doing
the mathematics
and you get this spectrum of
particles or this spectrum.
So who do you get
around this problem?
HONG LIU: This is
not the problem.
This is a fact of life.
This is just what you find.
AUDIENCE: So which one is right?
HONG LIU: They
both can be right,
and they both can be wrong.
And our goal is just to find
all possible theories are there.
And this just allow
the quantizations.
A lot consists in
And both of them give you
consistent quantum gravity.
And if I have time, if this is
a string theory class, if this
were a string
theory class, then I
would explain that actually
secretly they are equivalent,
secretly they are equivalent.
So in some sense, they
are not that different.
Anyway, for your purpose,
at the perturbative level,
when we can see that the
string coupling to be small,
then they appear
to be different,
and yeah, we have two
types of strings here.
And so let me mention a
little bit about those forms.
All of these are
anti-symmetric potentials,
so these anti-symmetric
potentials
are generalizations of the
Maxwell fields, of the Maxwell
field A mu.
So mathematically, you can
write-- say for example,
mathematically you can
write the gauge field A mu
as the so-called 1-form,
so-called 1-form, and then
A mu, it just coefficients
of this 1-form.
And then the field strings
is just so the derivative,
it's just exterior
derivative of this 1-form.
And then the
Lagrangian will be just
minus one quarter
F mu mu, F mu mu
construct from this procedure.
So you can just
general-- mathematically
straightforward to
generalize this you
have dimension of forms.
So for example, we
can consider n-form,
which is the n-component
tensor, but all indices
are fully anti-symmetric
with each other.
So all the indices are fully
anti-symmetric with each other.
So these are fully
anti-symmetric.
If they depend on
the conventions,
sometimes we also put the
one over n-factorial here.
So you can define such objects,
such as the generalization
of A, and the corresponding
field strings for this C,
we also called F. So
the field strings for C
is just a n plus 1-form, which
is exterior derivative of dC.
And then this is n plus 1-form.
Again, this is a fully
anti-symmetric tensor
now with n plus 1 indices.
And then you can write down
your Lagrangian similarly
by generalizing these,
you can write s1
over-- let me write it here--
you can write the Lagrangian s
minus 1 over 1/2 times
n factorial-- 2 times
n factorial, not 2n factorial--
2 times n factorial F mu1,
mu n plus 1, F mu1 mu n plus 1.
So F is n plus 1-form, so it's
a tensor of n plus 1 indices,
fully anti-symmetric
fully anti-symmetric.
So those fields essentially
have this kind of structure,
essentially have this
kind of structure.
And say the 1-form is very
similar to our Maxwell.
So this is a 3-form and
this is a scalar, then just
a massless scalar,
then this is a 2-form
whose field string
will be a 3-form,
and then this is
a 4-form factor.
And then just by
definition, just like here,
there's a gauge symmetry
because F equal to dA, here,
because this is F equal to dC.
So there's a gauge
symmetry because I
can add C n, the total
derivative, of any n plus 1,
n minus 1-form.
So I can make a gauge
symmetry, so lambda n minus 1
can be any n minus 1-form.
And because of this square equal
to zero, now F is invariant.
So F n plus 1 is invariant.
So if you put this into here,
and because this is already
a total derivative,
and so F is invariant.
So there's a great
symmetry, then
there will be a conserved charge
associated with those n-forms.
You can define conserved charge
So so far any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: And maybe, so
there's a C field that they
denoted fermions of bosons.
HONG LIU: Bosons,
it's all bosons.
AUDIENCE: But it looks--
so this anti-symmetric has
nothing to do with fermions?
HONG LIU: No, this
is just the indices.
This just indices which
are anti-symmetric.
This is not the location,
spacetime location.
This is just indices.
It's the same thing,
I think, F mu mu.
F mu mu, the indices
are anti-symmetric.
It's the same thing here.
Are the people comfortable
with this differential form
notation?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
HONG LIU: Bosons,
they're all bosons.
AUDIENCE: And where are
the partners of those?
HONG LIU: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Hb and phi,
where are their partners?
HONG LIU: So far I did
not write them down.
So they are also fermionics.
They are also massless fermions.
We will not need to
worry about them.
So they are massless
fermions in this.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
HONG LIU: Right.
AUDIENCE: With superstrings.
HONG LIU: Yeah those
just come from,
because when you go
to the superstring,
you have additional
fermions on the world-sheet.
And then they can give you
additional massless modes
essentially come from them.
The story, the real story is
a little bit more complicated
because actually
in the superstring,
even those come from the
fermions, world-sheet fermions.
Yeah but anyway vehicle
you have at the formula
for the world-sheet, then you
have more possibilities then
that give rise to those modes.
That's the long story.
AUDIENCE: Those modes are also
for bosons, not for fermions?
HONG LIU: No, these are all of
the spacetime bosonic fields,
which are low energy
excitations of the strings.
And how they arise
on the world-sheet,
whether they come from
fermions or from bosons
on the world-sheet,
it's a separate issue.
And, in fact, all
of them actually
arise from world-sheet fermions,
but they are spacetime bosons.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] of
these Ramond-Ramond fields?
HONG LIU: Yeah, you just
workout their repetitions
under their say,
Lorentz symmetry.
They're all integer
spin-- they're
all integer spin-- they're
all integer spin repetitions
of the Lorentz group.
And not like fermions,
then will be half integer.
They are generating repetitions
of the rotational group.
AUDIENCE: So they are
like spin 2, spin--
HONG LIU: No, normally we don't
call them spin 2 or spin three.
When we call spin 2, we mean
a fully symmetric indices,
symmetric and traceless.
AUDIENCE: But anti-symmetric,
we would never call them--
HONG LIU: Yeah, we
don't call them spin.
Just the repetitions
of the Lorentz group,
it's-- it's just some
repetitions of it's integer.
Good?
And in the case of the Maxwell,
we know that for the 1-form,
for the case of the Maxwell, its
source, where for A, its source
is a point particle.
So we can couple the--
so the point particle
interact say with
this extender vector
potential in the following way.
So suppose a particle following
some trajectory described
by x mu tau, and
then this particle,
we are intact with this vector
potential in the following way.
This is familiar from
E and M. So you just
integrate essentially with
A along the trajectory
of the particle.
And you can write this in the
more compact mathematical form.
You just say you integrate
along the trajectory
and A is a 1-form, and you
just integrate this 1-form
along the trajectory.
And so this is so-called pull
back of this 1-form A to C.
So this is the
mathematical language.
Similarly, we can generalize to
these higher dimensional forms.
So 1-form, naturally coupled
to a point particle--
which can be considered as
a zero-dimensional object.
So a p plus 1-form, then
naturally-- I should say
is fermion.
Then a p-dimensional object
that naturally couples-- just
as a generalization of
this-- to a p plus 1-form.
As follows, you can
just-- the worldvolume
of a p-dimensional object is a
surface of p plus 1 dimension.
So the worldvolume of
p-dimensional objects--
p plus 1 dimensions
because there's also time.
You also move in the-- it's
a p-dimensional object moving
the time, then in the
p plus one dimension.
So let me call that
worldvolume sigma.
And then the
naturalization of this
will be this, the coupling
between a p-dimensional object
to a p plus 1-form
will be like this.
Just you integrate
this p plus 1-form
on the worldvolume of
this p-dimensional object.
And again, this is
the pull back of C
to sigma, C plus 1 to sigma.
And let me just write it
in a more explicit form.
So here I use tau to
parametrize the trajectory
along the [INAUDIBLE].
So here, let me use
psi to parametrize
the worldvolume
coordinate of this brane.
Then this pull back means mu
1, mu p plus 1, partial x mu
1, partial psi 1, partial x mu
p plus 1, partial psi p plus 1.
And x mu psi one,
psi zero to psi p
describe the embedding
of sigma in spacetime.
Any questions on this?
So it tells you that-- so
this just tells you that the
AUDIENCE: There is
[INAUDIBLE] p plus 1 back
there could say zero because
of p because of notation.
HONG LIU: Let me just do zero.
AUDIENCE: Yes, so here
the p-dimensional object
in the simple case is just
like the point particle
is a zero-dimensional object.
So that's what the object is.
HONG LIU: That's right.
The zero-dimensional object
naturally couple to 1-form
in this way.
And then a p-dimensional
object naturally couple to a p
plus 1 dimensional this way.
So let me just make,
in the Maxwell case,
the gate symmetry here
implies an electric charge is
conserved, OK, the electrical
charge is conserved.
So for a p-dimensional
object coupled
to a p plus 1 dimensional
form, and because
of this gate symmetry and then
this charge is also conserved.
In particular, the object
with minimal charge
must be a stable object because
there's nothing to decay to.
So again, after generalization
of this case, so
in the standard story, in the
standard electromagnetism,
we can have an
electrically-charged particle,
we can also have a
magnetically-charged particle.
We can have a
In particular, you can talk
about the magnetic monopole
in quantum mechanics
and et cetera,
even though we have
not observed them.
So similarly one can
generalize that concept
to higher dimensions.
So let me first just
remind you of how
we define the magmatic--
the mathematical way of how
we define the
magnetically-charged object EM.
So EM-- so because
F is a 2-form,
we can dualize F-- so
this is Hodge dual.
We can define
another form, which
I call F tilde, which is related
to original F by Hodge dual.
So this is a 2-form,
the Hodge dual
of a 2-form in the four
dimension is another 2-form.
And then I can write it
as the total derivative
with another 1-form potential.
And then the object-- so you
know that the under this dual,
so F 0,1 is mapped
to F tilde 2, 3.
So the electric field is
mapped to the magnetic field,
and similarly, the
magnetic field here
is mapped to the electric field
here, so under this Hodge dual,
under this Hodge dual.
I should not just write this.
So after some minus sign
we'll not keep track of,
and under this Hodge
dual, you essentially
say the electric field
now I call magnetic field.
So now object
coupled to a tilde,
then it's magnetically charged.
Because in terms of
A tilde, such objects
they generate electric fields,
and from our original F point
there is a magnetic fields.
So there will be a
magnetically-charged object.
So essentially that's how we
think about the magnetic moment
pole, EM.
So this can also be generalized
to this n-form case.
So one can also
dualize an n-form.
Is that we introduce use
a lot of C tilde, which
is the dual of dC.
So dC is the field strength
for C. So this is n-form.
And the dC is the
field strength of C,
and then I do a Hodge dual, and
then I define to be dC tilde.
I define to be dC tilde.
And the dC tilde--
so this is n-form.
When you do a field strength
become n plus 1-form.
And when you do the Hodge dual,
when you take the Hodg-- dual,
the Hodge dual of
n-form is D minus n, OK?
So this is D min n minus 2.
So this should be a D
minus n minus 2-form
because when you
take the D, then that
makes into D minus
n minus 1-form,
and this Hodge dual
take this n plus 1-form
into D minus n minus 1 form.
So you map your n-form to
a D minus n minus 2-form.
So essentially,
it's the integration
of the electric-magnetic
dual of E and M.
So now you can couple a D minus
n minus 3-dimensional object
to C tilde.
And in terms of C, in
terms of regional C--
so this is a
magnetic object, OK?
Just the same as we
define magnetic object
or magnetic monopole for
E and M. So is the clear?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: In order to
write F tilde and A tilde,
do we have to assume that
there are no electric charges?
HONG LIU: That's a good point.
No, you don't have
to-- so you do this,
you have to assume that
the equation of motion
is satisfied.
You have to assume the equation
of motion is satisfied,
then you can write
this procedure.
AUDIENCE: So if dF is equal
to J, then that is non-zero.
So if there are--
HONG LIU: So you have the
exact the same situation
with E and M. It's just
identical situation
whatever you do in E and M
you do it here.
AUDIENCE: So I thought
that we could only
write F equals to
dA because there
were no magnetic monopole?
HONG LIU: No, so
you can do that,
now you have to introduce
some similarity,
so that's why the magnetic
monopole have a Dirac string.
That's why the magnetic
monopole have a Dirac string,
then you have this Dirac
quantization condition,
et cetera.
So as you would then,
say either in E and M,
or in the quantum mechanics,
say in the graduate quantum
mechanics, or E and M.
So are people familiar with the
concept of magnetic monopole
and the Dirac-- so-called Dirac
string and Dirac quantization
condition?
Yeah, I saw some nodding heads.
So you're not familiar
with it, then look at,
for example, in one
chapter of Jackson
have a very detailed discussion
of magnetic monopoles.
But the best, actually,
was Dirac's original paper.
It was really beautiful,
very, very beautiful.
But Jackson has a rather
pedagogical discussion.
Jackson's in actual
dynamics, that's a rather--
AUDIENCE: Does he discuss the
differential forms, though,
or no?
HONG LIU: I don't remember.
Oh, you mean Jackson?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
HONG LIU: I don't remember.
Yeah, it's the fact that you
can allow the magnetic monopole
then if you allow the certain
singularities in the vector
potential.
And that's the
so-called Dirac string.
So you don't have a thing to do.
So the idea is that you--
what you were saying is right,
the fact that you
could write F as dA
means there's no
magmatic source,
but you can introduce
a magnet source
if you allow certain
singularities,
and that's what Dirac realized.
Good.
So now, this other gauge
fields, in type IIA and type
IIB string, and
they can give rise
to extended objects
which couple to them.
And it turns out
the extended object
cover to those Ramond-Ramond
fields, are precisely D-branes.
And they are precisely
D-branes, and because they
couple to those gauge fields,
and they are stable objects.
At least the minimally-charged
ones are stable objects.
So this is related to the
statement that actually
in superstring you actually
find some stable branes.
And the other
dimensions-- so let
me just list them just to--
So with this preparation,
then in IIA, so we can have the
following electric and fully
magnetic object.
See in the IIA we have a C mu1.
We have a 1-form.
So that means there's a
natural object coupled to it--
electric object coupled to it.
Turns out this is a D0-brane.
A zero-dimension object coupled
to a 1-form, this is D0-brane.
And as a 1-form
in 10 dimension--
so in superstring we have
10 dimension-- is dual to--
so D is 10 minus 1
is 9, minus 3 is 6,
and a then the magnetic
object will be a D6-brane.
So similarly we have a
3-form, and then this
gave an electric D2-brane,
and a magmatic D4-brane.
So if you just follow this rule.
So for the type IIB, so let me
now first start with this C2.
So this gives you a D-string
one-dimensional object
coupled to it for the D-string.
And then the
mathematical object will
be a five-dimensional object.
It's called a D5-brane.
So this string is a D1-brane.
So now, let's look
at this 4-form.
So the so-called self-dual--
so sometimes we put a plus here
to indicate this is a self-dual.
So let me now explain
what this self-dual means.
So self-dual means that from
C4, as we construct an F5--
and construct an
F5 from this C4--
to be a self-dual form means
that this forms satisfies
the condition that
F5 equal to F5 dual.
So this is a self-dual.
Just means this is a constraint
that this C has to satisfy.
So this is called
a self-dual 4-form.
If you look at repetitions
of the Lorentz symmetry,
you'll find that this is
actually a repetition.
And so for this C,
you have to satisfy
this self-duality condition.
Then now, for object
which coupled to the C,
would be a naturally
D3-brane because
the three-dimensional
object coupled to a 4-form,
so it would be a D3-brane.
And this D3-brane, because of
this self-duality condition,
we have to be both electrically
and magnetically-charged
because this is
a self-dual form.
So this must source
both electric flux
and the magnetic flux to be
consistent with self-duality.
And then finally,
you can also have
a scalar field in the type IIB.
And the scalar field,
now eventually you
will couple to so-called the
D minus 1 dimensional brane.
Because scalar field, by
itself, is zero dimension.
It's already zero
dimensional form.
So following this
convention we will
couple to a D minus
1 dimensional brane.
And that obviously
not make much sense,
but actually can make sense when
you go to Euclidean signature,
and then it turns out
this scalar fields
couple to something
called the instanton,
which I will not go into there.
Something called D-instanton.
So the bottom line
is that the object,
they are charged under
[INAUDIBLE] fields,
they are all D-branes.
They are all D-branes, and they
come into those dimensions.
And any D-brane-- of
course you can define
D-branes with other dimensions.
So you can consider
in IIA a D3-brane.
But in IIA, a D3-brane
will not be a stable object
because there's not conserved
charge for you to couple to.
So even though in IIA you
can consider a D3-brane,
but it's not a stable
object, and actually,
when you quantized the spectrum
on the D3-brane in IIA, then
you find there's a tachyon.
Again there's a tachyon in
the worldvolume that indicates
that's not a stable object.
But those branes
don't have a tachyon.
And in particular,
on those branes,
these are all
supersymmetric field series.
For example, the
most important one
is this D3-brane
because then you
have four dimensions
of worldvolume,
then you actually have
four-dimension theory
on this D3-brane,
and that's what
gives you so-called
super-Yang-Mills theory.
So on these branes, on
these stable branes,
all of the theories--
super-Yang-Mills theory,
in particular for D3, it's
given by a so-called n
equal to four super-Yang-Mills
theory in four dimensions.
AUDIENCE: So what you're saying
is for any sign table, does
it mean dissolving--
HONG LIU: Yeah, it can decay.
It can decay.
AUDIENCE: But you lower
dimension of brane?
HONG LIU: It's possible
for it to decay
into lower dimensional
brane, and it can also
for it just to decay
into closed string modes,
radiated closed string modes.
AUDIENCE: But, I mean the
dimensions of these two objects
are different.
It sounds like if branes
decay to a string,
it will become infinite string.
HONG LIU: Yeah, that's right,
ud type density of strings.
It's actually a
beautiful subject
to discuss those
branes, how they decay.
Yeah, it's a nice subject, but
it's way out of our discussion
here.
Any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: As to four, if we
consider stacks of such branes,
do we get higher-ranked
age groups?
HONG LIU: Yeah, that's right.
Exactly.
It always give you n.
Good, so that concludes our
discussion of the D-branes
from the point of view as
the rich boundary conditions.
So now, I want to take a
slightly different perspective
on the D-branes.
From this perspective,
from the perspective
the object, which are
charged under those
generalized gauge fields.
And now I want to
view those D-branes.
I have some objects,
some solitons,
if you want some
solitons, which are
charged under those
generalized gauge fields.
I want elaborate from
this perspective.
I talk about the
different perspective.
So D-brane has
math, has tension.
Also D-brane carry--
so now we only
consider those stable D-branes.
So they have a mass, they
also carry those charges,
conserved charges.
So that means there will
be flux coming out--
electrical or magnetic flux
coming out of those branes.
So that will deform
the spacetime
because the gravity
will deform spacetime.
And so now, we'd
like to find out
what are the spacetime
around those D-branes.
How do they deform spacetime?
So for example, say
it consider charge
as a total example of this.
Say, let's consider just
again in the Maxwell theory,
in Einstein-Maxwell theory,
consider, for example,
a charged particle
sitting at the origin
of a four-dimensional
spacetime, Minkowski spacetime,
for example.
So if you include
both GR and E and M,
then the dynamics of
this series controlled
by so-called
Einstein-Maxwell-- so you
will have a Einstein
theory and the Maxwell.
So the dynamics
of such particles
should be captured by them.
And so this captures the
gravity due to the particle.
This captures E and M
due to the particle.
So from here, you can work out
how does this particle deform
spacetime from the
Einstein equation?
So the equation
motion of this system
would be, you have
a standard Maxwell--
so I will be careful about
the minus sign-- and also
the Einstein equation,
the stress tensor.
So j is just the-- if I have a
charged particle sitting there,
there's no current, there's
only a charged density.
And the stress tensor
contains two parts.
It's the stress tensor
due to the particle
and also the stress due to
the electromagnetic fields.
Because this excited the
electrogmagnetic fields.
And the particle part only
have a zero component,
so you only have a mass.
There's no momentum.
So this is just a--
maybe I should write r.
I think I'm using
the notation of r.
So the particle part
of the stress tensor
would be just the data function.
The only non-zero component
are zero-zero component.
You only have energy
density and just given
by the data function
of the mass.
So from here, by
solving those equations
we see those forces
then you can work out
how a charged particle
deforms your spacetime.
So let me just say
I'm a bit further,
for example you can easily
solve the Einstein equation,
we all know the
solutions, so you just
have a coulomb potential,
and in other words
you have electric
flux surrounding
the s2 around the point
particle, you go to q.
Again, this is the dual of F.
You have electric field, when
you dualize that hyperspatial
component, then that gives you
the-- so this a Gauss node, OK?
This is a Gauss node.
And you can also work out
the metric surrounding
this charged particles.
So because of the spacetime
symmetric, spherical symmetric,
then you can actually write down
the spherical symmetric ansatz
for the metric
around the particle.
So from the Einstein equation,
you can find out what's-- you
can work out what
is f(r) and h(r).
Some of you may have already
done this exercise before.
So if your q is zero,
what answer would you get?
That's right.
So if the q is
zero, then you just
get the Schwarzschild metric.
And it's the exactly
the metric say produced
by a song, et cetera, far away.
So here we have a
charge, then what
you get is something called
the Reissner-Nordstrom metric.
And when you have a charge
having electromagnetic fields.
So you will get so-called
Reissner-Nordstrom metric.
AUDIENCE: So that's
if q equals 0?
If q equals 0?
HONG LIU: No, q larger equal to
zero is the Reissner-Nordstrom.
And when q equal to
zero, then you just
get the Schwarzschild That's how
you calculate the precession.
That's what you use to calculate
the precession of, say,
of the mercury.
Similarly, you can
also do this for
magnetically-charged particle.
So the only difference for
magnetically-charged particle,
the difference is
that this equation now
becomes just directly
magnetic flux
equal to G. Say for example,
if the magnetic charge is G,
and then you will get this.
Then instead you have
this, and then you
have yeah-- We have
a magnetic flux.
And again, you could
plug into any equation
you solve, you get the same
Reissner-Nordstrom metric.
It's also a Dirac
quantization telling you
that the qg should be quantized
in integers of 2 pi n-- so n
equal one, two, et cetera.
So this is the familiar
story in the GR,
so if you want to look at how
the gravity and the E and M
surrounding the charged objects,
and so you can generalize
this story immediately
to those branes, which
are charged-- which
have their own mass
and charged under some
generalized gauge fields.
So you can generalize
that immediately.
procedure immediately
to higher-dimension objects.
So you can just, as a
single exercise in GR,
you can just carry
out this procedure,
just replace this to some
higher-dimensional form,
under the source is some
higher-dimensional object,
then you can work
out the solutions.
And that was a simple exercise
which actually Horowitz
and Strominger-Dietz,
in the early '90s,
in 1991, it's a trivial
generalization you can do,
why not do it?
But turns out that's a
very, very important step
to do for the reason
which I will explain.
So for simplicity, let
me just talk a little bit
about doing this
for this D3-brane,
also for definite entities, you
could do it for any of this.
And let me just say
it for D3-brane.
So now consider the D3-brane--
so D3-brane is part of the type
IIB theory, so of course,
we don't know to really do
this in the full
type IIB string,
so we will do the low energy
limit of the type IIB sting.
So we will do this
for the D3-brane.
In the low energy limit
of type IIB stream,
which is so-called
type IIB supergravity.
So it doesn't matter that
you don't learn anything
about type IIB.
Supergravity, and
essentially, that's
just some generalization
of this equation.
Type IIB supergravity
is some generalization
of this equation.
But nevertheless let me just
introduce some notations just
to be-- So type
IIB supergravity--
we will do this in the law
of limit of the IIB string.
So this is the law
energy effective theory
for massless modes
of IIB string.
So it has the form as
what we had before.
You have 1 over 6 pi, T pi GN.
But not this is a
10-dimensional Newton constant,
so this is a 10-dimensional
theory equal to 10.
And you have the Einstein
term, and then you
have forms associated with all
of this flux, generalized gauge
fields, et cetera,
fermions, et cetera.
And as we said before, the
relation with string theory,
the Newton constant should be
proportional to gs squared.
So you can actually work
out the prefactor precisely.
So let me just write
down the prefactor.
So the relation with
the string is-- just
on the dimensional ground,
so this is the Newton
constant in 10
dimensions, so this
would have dimension
eight in terms of the lens
have dimension eight.
So the right-hand side I must
be upper prime to the power 4
because this is only lens
scale in string theory.
And then the prefactor,
it turned out
to be-- so you can
work out the prefactor,
so turns out 16 pi GN is
equal to 2 pi to the power 7.
Say, when you work out the
law energy effective theory,
you can work out
this precise factor.
And the regime of the
validity of this type IIB
supergravity is that the gs
is much, much smaller than 1.
The string [INAUDIBLE] should
be much, much smaller than 1.
So that just tells-- this is
a statement the string loop
correction should be
small because the when
the string become big,
the loop correction
become more and more important.
The loop correction
would be more and more
important from the
point of view of gravity
this quantum
gravitational corrections.
And so when G string become
big, the quantum gravitational
corrections-- so spacetime
will fluctuate more.
And then of course you cannot
trust the classical gravity
in that region.
So if you want to trust
the classical gravity,
you want to have small
coupling, or translate
into this language, the Newton
constant has to be small.
OK?
The Newton constant
has to be small.
That means the gravity's weak.
But in real life,
gravity's weak, so it's OK.
And so this means the
quantum correction is small,
so you can trust the
classical gravity.
So you can trust
And then we also want
the energy-- no energy,
so we want energy
squared to be smaller
then one over alpha prime.
Because when energy squared
becomes more than one
over alpha prime, then
the massless string modes
become important because
all of the massless
string modes have mass square
of one over alpha prime.
And if we only
want to concentrate
on the massless modes, and then
you don't want to excite them.
And also you want the curvature
of the spacetime-- here
we're considering
curve spacetime--
so you want the curvature
to be much smaller than one
over alpha prime.
So this gravity,
essentially, when
you consider the mass
of this particle,
you consider the particle
limit of the spacetime.
So this can be
considered-- as you
can see, the
spacetime curvature--
the spacetime curvature radius
is much much-- so alpha prime
is essentially it gives us the
rough lens scale of a string.
And then when the curvature
is much, much smaller than one
over alpha prime, that means
that the sight of the string
is tiny compared to
the curvature radius,
the typical size of your system.
And that you can roughly
treat them as point particles,
and that's what the
gravity theory does.
In the supergravity theory
it's all point particles.
And so this means we
decouple massless modes.
So you can count
on massless modes.
So whenever you take
a limit, you always
have to take the
dimensionless number small.
So the dimensionless
number is alpha
prime times curvature, of
alpha times energy squared.
But in reality, we often--
when we work with a theory,
we often just keep
our curvature,
or our energy scale
as what we want.
And then in talking
about this limit,
we just say, we take alpha
prime goes to zero limit.
We say we take alpha
So that means a law
of energy limit.
Even though, legitimately,
this is not the right thing
to say because this is the
dimensional prime integral.
And so the regime where
supergravity works,
can be formulated, say, as
alpha prime goes to zero
and the g string goes to 0.
So in this regime, now you
can work with supergravity,
and now you can now generalize
this story to the branes.
Now generalize this
story for branes.
So now let me say a few things
about the D-branes-- D3-branes.
So they D-brane, D3-brane's
charged under C 4
plus-- process and
we said this C 4 plus
is required to be self-dual.
That means any
source of C 4 plus
must carry both electric
and magnetic charge.
So that means that
for the D3-brane-- say
if we define an electric
charge to be-- So now,
so the D3-brane is a
three-dimensional object
and the transverse direction is
a six-dimensional because this
is 3 plus 1 including time,
so the transverse direction
is six-dimensional.
So we can similarly just
think about the D3-brane.
So if we ignore the spatial
direction along the brane, then
the D3-brane, the
transverse direction
then can be just considered
a point in R6, OK?
So a way to think about the
D3-brane, the surrounding
of the D3-brane, it's an
analog of a point in R6,
in the six-dimensional space.
Is this clear?
This is going to
be very important.
And then the surrounding this
point, the sphere will S5.
Just like in the electric case,
just like the E and M case,
this is the S2 surround
the point particle,
and this S5 is the
sphere, which is
surrounding the whole D3-brane.
And then this D3 can have
electric and magnetic flux
through this S5.
And so electric charge would
be just the 5-form running
through it.
And the magnetic charge
would be just-- right.
Minus the dual of
5-form is 1-form--
just make the relation
between these two.
And now because of
self-duality condition,
then they must be the same.
So that means for the D3-brane,
the electric and magnetic
charge must be the same.
And also for
higher-dimensional object--
AUDIENCE: Excuse me, why
should they be the same?
Why not--
HONG LIU: It's because
of F5, you get F5 star.
It's because of that.
Because of that
self-dual condition.
So electric and magnetic
charge of the D3-brane
must be the same.
It must carry both electric
and magnetic charge.
And now, this Dirac
quantization condition
also works for
higher-dimensional objects.
And again, it's a
very simple exercise
to do it-- very simple
exercise to generalize Dirac's
argument to higher dimension.
Again, it's just
related to how you
treat those higher-dimensional
forms, et cetera.
Again, it's a very simple step,
but it's a very important step.
So that tells mu that's for
D3-brane, which is self-dual,
which carry both electric
and magnetic charge,
then you have to satisfy
this quantization condition.
Then that means the
minimal single D3-brane,
the minimally-charged
object, the charge
must be square root of 2 pi.
And for n of them, it must D3
equal to q3 equal to 2 pi n.
So now we have to
specify the analog
for E and M, those conditions.
Now we also have to specify
the mass of the D3-brane.
So as we discussed
before, tension
over the D3-brane,
tension over D-brane
should be proportional
to one over gs.
That you also did
in your P-sets.
And again, by doing a
precise calculation,
you can work out the
precise prefactors.
It turns out actually to
be the following form.
It's the q3 divided by 16 pi GN.
And the GN is just gs
squared, so if you translate
into-- so for n D3-brane,
that would be n divided
by 2 pi cubed gs
alpha prime squared.
So this gs and
alpha prime squared
we know on general grounds.
So gs we'd-- one over gs
we know on general ground,
and alpha prime squared just
from dimensional analysis.
Because this is a
three-dimensional object,
the tension we'll
have mass dimension
4, so that's why you have one
over alpha prime squared here.
And then the other 2 pi cubed
from precise calculations.
And you can also
write it in this form
in terms of Newton constants.
And the reason I write
this form because this
is a very special case.
And you see that the tension
is actually precisely related
to the charge and divided by
the square root of Newton's
constant.
And it turns out that
only special objects
have this kind of property.
And this is so-called
BPS objects.
I will not go to there.
It's related to those branes
that are supersymmetric.
Anyway, so these are the
mass over the-- essentially,
this is the mass of
the brane, and these
are the charge of the brane.
When you specify the charge,
than those fields, then
those flux that you
uniquely determined,
and then the C4 potential
up to gauge symmetry
are determined.
And then now you can plug
into the generalization
of the Einstein equation
to work out the geometry.
So again, the symmetry
here-- I won't
have time for the bottom
line, so that's OK.
So the symmetry
preserved by the D-brane,
by D3-brane as we said before,
similar to all D-branes
is you have a Poincare symmetry
along the brane direction,
and then you have
rotational symmetry
in the transverse
direction along the brane.
So the transverse we
have six dimensions.
So there's SO(6) directions
you can rotate in the--
and then you have Poincare
symmetry in the (1,3)
direction.
So based on these symmetries
you can write down
what the metric looks like.
You can write down
answers for the metric.
Just like right here,
you can write down
the answers for the metric
of a point particle based
on symmetry.
So here, if you can write down
the answers for the metric
based on symmetry.
So first, you should
have a part which
is preserved Poincare symmetry.
Means that this part
can only be this form.
Say along the brane
direction, can only
be this form times
some other factor which
depends on r, so r is
the transverse radius
from the brane.
And then, the other dimension
must be spherical symmetric,
so you can have
a lot of factors.
And then the r squared
d omega 5 squared.
So this is s5
surrounding the brane,
and then this is the
radial direction.
So this is the only
form of the metric.
And then essentially, again, as
in the charged particle case,
you need to determine
these two functions.
Which you can plug in
the Einstein equation
to determine these
two functions.
So let me just write down
the form of those functions,
then we discuss what
they mean next time.
Some how, this year I'm
consistently much, much slower
than what I did before.
Maybe I'm explaining
physics better.
Anyway, so now it's just
a mechanical exercise.
You plug in these answers
into the Einstein equation,
then you can find the two
equations for f and h,
then you can solve it.
In the old days, when Horowitz
and Strominger did it--
maybe they did not
have Mathematica yet,
but nowadays you can do it.
Using Mathematica, if you
have the right program,
you can do it in five minutes.
But in the old days-- they
were friends with Wolfram,
maybe they already have
the program at that time.
Anyway, so it was a [INAUDIBLE]
exercise to do at the time.
So you find actually the
answer is very simple.
Turns out, both f
and h, they just--
can be written in
the following form.
H is just a harmonic function.
And R to the power 4 is
given by some constant GN,
Newton's constant times the
D3-brane tension times n.
And it can also be written as
4 pi gs N alpha prime squared.
So turns out that those
functions are very simple.
They just square root
of a harmonic function.
So this is a harmonic function
for the transverse R6.
So if you solve a
coulomb problem,
and that will be the solution.
And this is the harmonic-- so
this is the generalization of 1
over R potential.
So this is just generalization
of 1 over R potential.
And then f and g is very simply
related to this by square root.
And this constant R to the power
4, so this is not curvature,
this is just some constant.
I'm using the standard notation.
And then this can be--
this is just related
to the mass of the brane.
Mass of the brane, of
course, is proportional to n.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: In this
case, is the mass,
the charge is it massless?
HONG LIU: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: The
charge is massless?
HONG LIU: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Is the charge
considered on the D3-brane
brane massless or massive?
HONG LIU: No.
Charge are just charge.
What do you mean by
charge is massless?
This is just the charge
carried by this D3-brane.
Anyway, so this R4 is just
like GN times the tension,
N have the tension.
We have n objects.
So this is what you're
familiar with the Schwarzschild
black hole.
Schwarzschild metric just
using constant times mass,
so this is just
generalization of that.
The Newton constant times the
tension, and you have n-branes,
we just multiply n.
And you write it-- if you
write everything from gs,
this is a proponent
to gs squared,
to one over gs,
so and that, the thing's
proportionate to gs.
OK.
OK we'll stop here.